Sud Radio l'invité
politique Jean-Jacques Bourdin il est
8h34 bonjour à toutes et à tous merci
d'être avec nous les français veulent
savoir parlons vrai ce matin avec Marc
fenau ministre de l'Agriculture Marc fen
bonjour bonjour merci d'être avec nous
la colère des agriculteurs ne faiblit
pas sur laass près de ringis ils sont
installés à quelques encablures de
ringis ils veulent encercler Paris
encercler
Lyon vous les empêcherez d'entrer dans
Paris d'entrer dans Lyon d'entré à
ringis les choses ont été très
clairement dites par le Premier ministre
et par le ministre de l'intérieur peut
pas être question et d'ailleurs la
plupart d'entrex le disent de bloquer ce
sont des des travailleurs les les les
exploitants agricoles et ils savent ce
que c'est aussi que d'être travailleurs
pour les autres francilien pour ceux qui
sont à Lyon ou ailleurs il peut pas être
question d'avoir un blocus du telle ou
telle ville Paris et et les grandes
métropoles régionales et donc l'objectif
c'est bien d'abord de dialoguer mais on
va y revenir pour apporter un certain
nombre de réponses concrètes et puis
deux de pas se retrouver dans une
situation qui soit une situation de
blocus parce que je pense que c'est
c'est mauvais pour tout le monde ce
genre de situation je comprends très
bien la colère hein c'est pas le sujet
je nélut pas ni la colère ni les
difficultés qu'il rencontre mais le les
principes ont été posés par le ministre
de l'Intérieur de ne pas en arriver à un
blocus un blocus de ringist blempêcherez
les agriculteurs d'entrer à rangis vous
les empêcherez d'entrer dans Paris vous
les empêcherez d'entrer dans Lyon c'est
c'est l'objectif on on a clairement fixé
les limites mais moi je voudraisigner
l'esprit de responsabilité de l'immense
majorité d'entre eux qui sont à des
points qu'ils ont identifié et qu'ils
ont identifié en bonne intelligence avec
les forces de l'ordre pour à la fois
dire ce qu'ils ont à dire et en même
temps ne pas entraver à un point tel la
liberté de circulation bien ils sont en
colère ils maintiennent leur blocus ils
le renforcent même ils attendent des
réponse Gabriel hatal hier a dit avec
Marc fen nous aurons l'occasion
d'annoncer des choses très très concrète
dans les heures et les jours qui
viennent alors ce matin vous êtes avec
nous j'attends moi des annonces très
concrète alors d'abord dire qu'on a fait
un certain nombre d'annonces je on
rentrera dans le détail si vous le
voulez vendredi dernier sur des mesures
de simplification qui sont d'un ordre
tout à fait inédit sur les délais sur le
retour au droit commun sur un certain
nombre de procédures parce que il y av
une une certaine une exception agricole
qui allit dans le mauvais sens
c'est-à-dire que vous faisiez un
bâtiment agricole
pour faire un recours contre une
procédure c'était 4 mois quand le délai
commun c'est l'urbanisme un certain
nombre de simplification dél passe à de
mois le délai passe à 2 mois ça fait ça
fait 20 ans que ça a duré hein donc on
est sur des simplifications assez
drastiques de ce qu'a exprimé le Premier
ministre sur les questions du GNR
c'était une demande très attendue avec
dès euh le mois de février de la
trésorerie en avance puisqu'on va
rembourser en anticipation une partie de
GNR de la du remboursement de la taxe
qui était prévu c'est plus de 200
millions d'euros qui sont prévus plus
une mesure de simplification au mois de
juin deuxième élément on continue à
travailler on continue avec les les
agriculteurs et leurs représentants
simplement m'arrêter quelques secondes
ou quelques minutes en particulier sur
cette radio sur les questions
viticolesou on a un sujet viticol vous
avez des annonces à faire pour les
viticulteurs on a un sujet viticool qui
est très grave d'abord dire qu'on avait
pris la mesure du problème puisque il y
avait des mesures qui avaient été prises
en 2023 donc on découvre pas tout à fait
qui était des mesures de distillation
pour 200 millions d'euros qui est une
mesure importantes et puis des mesures
de restructuration des prêts au travers
du glissement des prêts garantis par
l'État en prèbonifié la mesure peut se
mettre en place dès le début du mois de
février on va dialoguer avec les banques
parce qu'on a besoin de la solidarité de
la et la de l'Allan des banques sur ce
dispositif parce que c'est c'est dans
leur main que ce sera mais je rappelle
quand même que tout ça a été fait et
puis j'étais venu au mois de décembre
dans l'éos déjà pour le pour travailler
avec les représentants de la filière
viticolle donc je vrais saluer l'esprit
de responsabilité sur un certain nombre
de mesures conjoncturelles et
structurell alors mesure conjoncturell
80 millions d'euros qui permettront de
couvrir les aléas qu'on rencontré un
certain nombre de régions ça couvre
l'ensemble des régions viticoles qui
sont en crise évidment 80 millions
d'euros pour les viticulteurs pour les
viticulteurs qui permettra de couvrir
des aléas qu'on a pu avoir sur le MU
comme vous le savez et puis des
difficulté de trésorerie puisqu'on
prendra en charge les intérêts d'emprunt
sur l'année 2024 et donc c'est autant de
trésorerie qui va être dégagé pour les
viticulteurs l'état prendra en charge
les intérêts d'emprun sur l'année 2024
être très précis c'est ça et puis
l'ensemble des allées à oou des crises
qu'ils ont traversé du bord de lait
jusqu'à l'Occitanie parfois un peu en
Vallé du rô on prendra en charge les
difficultés qui sont liées à des
difficultés conjonctes
la crise m des affaires de prix et donc
soutien à la trésorerie ou soutien à la
perte qui est liée à telle ou telle
maladie ça c'est 80 millions d'euros
mais de en conscience quand on on est
dans une crise comme celle-là viticole
celle d'aujourd'hui mais la crise
viticole qu'on a derrière nous et sans
doute devant nous on a un sujet
structurel c'est-à-dire qu'on a un sujet
d'une baisse de
consommation de vin à l'intérieur de nos
frontières et à l'extérieur de nos
frontières en Europe et dans le monde
donc c'est une mesure structurelle de
150 millions d'euros cette mesure
structurelle elle visera à quoi visera à
arracher de manière temporaire les
vignes le temps de restructurer donc une
prime à l'arrachage en quelou absolument
c'est ça le temps que la la
restructuration se fasse et puis pour
ceux qui sont avec des dispositions
particulières c'est une prime
malarrachage qui pourrait être rendue
définitif pour motif de diversification
agricole c'est-à-dire que vous retirez
du volume provisoirement vous
restructurez ou vous retirez
définitivement pour faire de la
diversification agricole voilà les deux
deux j'arrache de la vigne pour cultiver
autre chose ch et donc on aura besoin
donc vous m'aidez vous m'aidez
financièrement à arracher ma vigne pour
planter autre chose pour planter autre
chose ou vous arrachez temporairement le
temps de restructurer y compris
qu'est-ce qu'on veut comme cpages voyez
c'est des choses qui ont déjà fait ça
concerne pour être précis ça peut
concerner jusqu'à 100000 hectares de
vignes 100000 he de Vig je rappelle
qu'il y a environ 700000 hectares de de
vigne en France donc c'est c'est
absolument massif oui comme comme plan
parce qu'on a besoin de répondre au
conjoncturel mais on sait que le sujet
de la consommation c'est un sujet qui
est devant nous et je sais que les les
professionnels le savent on a besoin de
travailler je serai cet après-midi à
Bruxelles pour rentrer dans le détail
j'allis vous en parler parce qu'on a
besoin de évidemment la mesure
conjoncturelle 80 millions c'est à la
main de l'État dans un cadre
réglementaire connu la mesure à 150
million maintenant on la travaille avec
Bruxelles je je dois vous avez besoin de
l'autorisation de Bruxelles bien sûr
parce que c'est un dispositif encadré
réglementir oui enfin jusqu'alors
jusqu'alors j'ai oui toujours obtenu ce
que j'estimais devoir obtenir à
Bruxelles on y viendra par exemple sur
les questions déjà cher qui a besoin de
travail que nous soyons dans un cadre
collectif parce que évidemment il y a
les demandes de même nature de nos amis
euh italien espagnol donc on va faire ce
que je fais depuis le début que je suis
ministre deagriculture construire
construire une coalition pour faire en
sorte que collectivement on dise en
conscience on a un sujet structurel en
conscience il y a des mesures en France
en Italie en Espagne bien Marc F voilà
pour les viticulteurs d'autres annonces
pour d'autres secteurs de l'agriculture
quand
alors c'est le premier ministre qui qui
les fera euh sans doute le premier
ministre s'exprimera parce qu'il y a un
moment avant la fin de la semaine avant
la fin de la semaine et on on verra on
verra le moment où il s demain ou
après-demain il s'exprimera rapidement
parce que nous avons vraiment ardamment
travaillé je crois que tout le monde le
reconnaît oui pour à la fois se poser
des questions de court terme mais aussi
se dire il y a des choses qui traînent
depuis trop longtemps il faut qu'onut
qu'on en finisse avec un certain nombre
de difficultés oui le Premier ministre
s'exprimera avant de la fin de la
semaine pour dire globalement ce qui est
la réponse qui sur des sujets de filière
puis qui sur des sujets plus généraux
euh c'est-à-dire qu'est-ce qu'on essaie
de de faire progresser dans la loi
égalime pour qu'elle marche loalim
qu'est-ce qu'on fait sur les questions
de de européenne alors le président le
président de la République sera alors
justement tiens cette semaine donc on
pour pour parler avec lui voilà vous
vous rendez à Bruxelles aujourd'hui le
président de la République sera demain à
Bruxelles il va rencontrer hurcela
vanerleyen demain il a des demandes
précises à lui faire j'imagine trois
axes les Jachet
les importations ukrainiennes de volaill
et trè axe évidemment le Mercosur alors
on va détailler les jacher le fameux 4 %
de terres qui doivent être mises en
jacher ça c'est la Pâque ça c'est la
pâac là est-ce qu'on va revenir sur ces
4 % de mise en jacher écoutez alors
d'abord dire que je travaille moi
personnellement sur le sujet depuis le
mois d'aût donc parfois il y a des
processus qui sont un peu longs et je
pense qu'on a un besoin ça c'est c'est
dans les années qui viennent
ouoseess Agil ou les proc plus Agil
parce que quand il y a des crises ça
peut pas être le pas de temps c'est
comme si je venais à votre radio ce
matin en vous disant rendez-vous dans 9
mois Monsieur Bourdin vous me diriez
c'est curieux quand même en terme
d'agilité et d'efficacité de la
puissance publique depuis le mois de
septembre nous avons travailler j'ai
pris le lit d'une coalition de près de
22 pays européens sur 27 ce qui est
quand même me semble-t-il assez
signifiant pour dire quoi pour dire à
l'heure où on importe en Europe 40
millions de tonnes de céréales 40
millions de tonnes pas en France en
France nous sommes export h mais 40
millions de tonnes se dire qu'on on on
consacre l'idée qu'il faudrait qu'il y
ait des terres totalement improductifes
parce que la jacher c'est totalement
improductif il y a quelque chose qui est
curieux on a fait une proposition à la
Commission européenne qui vise à la fois
à pouvoir remettre en culture mais dans
un cadre environnemental qui soit un
cadre respectueux l'idée c'est quand
même de tenir aussi sur le la question
de la rotation des cultures du du
stockage est- qu'on va remettre en
culture ces 4% de ce que j'entends et
pour finir mais je voulais juste vous
dire le processus parce que tout ça ça
vient jamais de rien voyez tout ça c'est
du travail des chos séri
ouiteur lui il attend la réponse j'ai
entendu j'ai entendu et vous allez avoir
la réponse que j'ai l'habitude de
répondre aux questions
euh la Commission européenne a dit hier
qu'elle allait faire une proposition on
va voir les termes de cette proposition
pour pour avoir cette dérogation sur la
Jach dérogation sur la JA donc j'ai très
bon espoir il y aura des expressions
aujourd'hui je discuterai avec le
commissaire à l'agriculture et et avec
d'autres et et demain lors du Conseil
européen il y aura des expressions pour
pour de donner droit au fond à quelque
chose qui relève du bon sens du bon sens
du bon sens on peut conjuguer
environnement transition et production
et ne pas mettre des terres en jacher
qui pourrai être exploité je me met à la
place de l'agriculteur qui voit ces
terres
inexploitable par que l'Europe a décidé
que on nallait pas exploiter telle ou
telle terreour ou c'est pas tout à fait
ça mais presque pres ne faisons pas de
l'Europe Bou émissaire non plus si vous
me permettez mais on a besoin nous oui
collectivement de regarder dans ce qui a
été ce qu'on appelit le Green Deal oui
oui il y a besoin de réduire les gaz à
effet de serre oui oui il y a besoin des
transitions écologiques mais pas au prix
d'une be de souveraineté européenne et
l'Europe doit avoir sa prise de
conscience on a vu le retard qu'on avait
pris sur les questions énergétiques et
d'autres et donc la souveraineté
énergétique c'est important la
souveraineté alimentaire c'est aussi
très important alors rétablir des droits
de douane sur les produits Ukrainiens
oui ou non euh l'objectif c'est bien ça
on va regarder la proposition l'objectif
c'est de rétablir des droits Dean non
c'est de alors c'est formulez-le c'est
en tout cas de faire en sorte que les
quotas qui avaient été en fait on a on a
on a abaissé complètement les droits de
douan sans sans limite sans limite les
premier mois ça n'a pas posé de problème
majeur simplement on a vu que c'est venu
déstabiliser un certain nombre de
marchés j'avais été le dire d'ailleurs à
mon collègue à Kiev quand j'étais venu à
kiief et à la vice-présidente
ukrainienne pour dire attention là vous
êtes en train d'atteindre les limites de
ce qui est acceptable pour la
déstabalisation des marchés donc l'idée
c'est de regarder un quantum qui
permettrait de dire au-delà de ce seuil
là on a on a forcément qu'on met des
quotas quoiàd que on peut importer sans
droit de douinee telle quantité de
poulet ukrainien mais au-delà de cette
quantité a ça relève de cette démarche
là donc on est en train d'affiner parce
qu'après c'est pardon je vais pas
rentrer dans le détail du coup mais
l'année de référence alors c'est
volaille la demande française c'est
volaille céréales sucre sucre parce
qu'on voit bien que ces marchés sont
déstabilisés alors une partie d'ailleurs
des mouvements européens parce que la
crise que nous avons elle est française
mais européenne européne notamment sur
le flan est de de de de l'Union
européenne elle est liée à ce sujet de
déstabilisation des March notamment elle
est lié à ce sujet de déstabilisation ce
qu'il faut c'est aider les Ukrainiens à
faire ce qu'ils avaient c'est-à-dire qu'
sortent les céréales qui sortent les
volailles d'Europe oui pour qu'ils
aillent sur les marchés qui étaient les
leurs initialement bien alors maintenant
un point important le
Mercosur parce que là il y a 3 jours
encore les négociations se poursuivaient
entre les négociateurs sud-américains et
les négociateurs européens ces
négociations ont été suspendues vous
confirmez ce que je dis hein les
informations effectivement que nous
avons bien elles ont été suspendues bon
maintenant est-ce que vous vous engagez
à abandonner définitivement l'accord
Union européenne Mercosur mais on
s'engage à faire en sorte pourquoi on on
refuse la France est d'ailleurs assez
assez seul sur cette position au niveau
européen faut se le dire donc c'est
jamais facile d'être seul dans ce genre
de de discussion mais c'est parce que la
France porte dans l'Union européenne et
que le Président de la République a fait
ce choix que pour l'instant nous n'avons
pas l'accord du Mercosur et pourquoi on
bute sur l'accord du Mercosur parce
qu'on considère que les pratiques
agricoles d' sur un certain nombre de
produits la trajectoire y compris en
terme de de de perspective climatique
n'est pas la bonne donc tant qu'on a pas
de réponse clair et tant qu'on a pas
quelque chose qui évite de mettre et de
livrer n nos producteurs français
européens à des clauses à une
concurrence qui soit une concurrence
déloyale il ne peut pas y avoir d'accord
de
Mercosur tant mais si vous avez ces
clauses mettant
à l'abri les agriculteurs français vous
signerez le merc non je dis pas ça je
dis on a besoin non je voudrais savoir
par vous comprenez il y a deux solutions
la France pourrait demander le retrait
du mandat de négociation dont dispose la
Commission de l'Union européenne la
France a le droit de faire ça je crois
pas que ça soit dans la procédure je
pense que c'est un mandat qui a été
donné sur lequel il faut revenir à la
majorité parce que il me semble que
c'est pas la France toute seule qui
décide du mandat de négociation de la
Commission peut toujours penser qu'on
est un peu sur une île déserte on d' d'
est suffamment puissante AUAU euré
Monsieur Bourdin pardon de vous dire je
vais vous répondre mais d'abord pardon
de vous dire du commerce avec le Brésil
du commerce avec l'Argentine il existe
hein mais bien sûr des poulets
brésiliens du Soj brésiliens donc ne
faisons pas croire que ces accords
viennent entraver déjà ce qui est une
liberté de circulation oui de fait des
produits donc moi je préfère qu'on
travaille sur qu'est-ce qu'on accepte
comme produit dans l'Union européenne et
quelle norme ils ont et qu'est-ce qu'il
pent comme charge de carbone par exemple
qu'est-ce qu'il porte comme charge voyez
ce que je veux dire qu'il faut qu'on
travaille parce que dire il y a pas
d'accord de libre échange c'est frère à
croire qu'il y aurait pas un jour des du
commerce entre nos deux donc il y aura
un jour un Mercosur signé par la France
verra on verra pour l'instant il y a des
accords vous avez le Mercosur ça fait 15
ans qu'il traîne he donc on a bien un
problème quand même manifestement si on
nobtient pas ce que nous voulons
c'est-à-dire des clauses de respect et
de réciprocité sur les pratiques
agricoles c'est-à-dire des chose qui
évite qu'on les livre en pâure il y a
pas d'accord du Mercosur c'est c'est
c'est ça la position française et pardon
de vous dire jusqu'alors cette position
elle été tenue bien les accords entre
l'Union européenne et le Chili entre
l'Union européenne et et la
Nouvelle-Zélande sont en cours de
ratification est-ce qu'il faut les
ratifier écoutez moi je vais vous dire
ce que je pense sur la globalement sur
la question des accords de librechange
d'abord on a besoin d'échanges agricoes
on a besoin d' change agricole pour deux
raisons d'abord tous les pays et tous
les États ne sont pas capables de
souvenir à leur besoins deuxième élément
on nous on n'est pas capable de subvenir
à nos besoins Agri oui mais oui mais
d'accord mais nous déjà nous sommes nous
sommes nous sommes sur un certain nombre
de production avec une grande capacité
d'exportation la moitié des céréales
françaises est sortent des frontières 25
% des céréales françaises elles sortent
des frontières de l'Union européenne le
fromage c'est 3 milliards d'euros
d'excédents commerciaux à l'extérieur de
nos frontières le lait c'est la moitié
des échanges qui se font à l'extérieur
de nos frontières donc on a une
puissance agricole et la France elle
n'est pas une puissance qui vient juste
au tars qui vient juste couvrir ses
besoins donc on a besoin d'accord alors
que ça soit des accords type ce que vous
vous évoquez ou d'autres accords
l'accord du CTA qui a été beaucoup
vilpand il est en cours hein h pour la
France c'est 120 millions d'euros de
plus d'export vis-à-vis du du Canada
pourquoi qu'est-ce qui s'est passé on a
dit qu'onacceptait pas que VI viennent
du Canada des bœufs qui seraiit produit
dans des conditions qui soi pas conforme
à celle que nous avions y compris en
termes climatiques comme quoi on peut
avoir des accords et qui soi favoraable
on a un accord de libre échange avec le
Japon le Japon c'est plus de 200
millions d'euros de d'exportation
supplémentaire pour les produits
agricoles français donc n'essayons pas
de on a besoin d'accord on a besoin
d'accord qui soit équilibré c'est-à-dire
qui respecte des contraintes
environnementales qui soient de même
nature que la nôtre et puis qu'on
défende en offensive ce que sont nos
intérêts alors tous les accords sont pas
équivalents et parfois on est plus
favorisé que dans d'autres accords
reconnaissons-le et on a besoin aussi de
de d'améliorer la compétitivité de nos
filières mais pensez j'entends certains
qui disent faut sortir de tous les
accords de libre échange c'est
immédiatement on ne sortira pas de tous
les accords de libre échange mais je
sais c'est c'est c'est quand vous vous
avez les chiffres que je vous donne
c'est c'est la mort de l'agriculture
française dans ce qu'elle a encore
d'exportateur et je vous ai pas parlé
vous vous aurez remarqué je ne vous ai
pas parlé du vin parce que c'est parfois
l'arbre qui cache la forêt mais on a
besoin mais on a besoin d'accord de
libre échange qui soit Loyau y compris
sur la question environnementale bien
Marc fen toutes les aides PAC versé sur
les comptes bancaires des exploitants
avant le 15 mars c'est la promesse faite
hier par le le Premier ministre
réduction des normes environnementales
vous allez réduire des normes
environnementales on a parlé desj chers
tout à l'heure c'est pas une réduction
des normes environnementales les non non
non mais enfin ça peut ça peut par CS
l'interprètent comme ça mais pardon
c'est le Green Deal mais oui mais si
l'environnement c'est la décroissance et
la mise sous cloche bah c'est un peu de
la décroissance maîre des terrangch
c'est bien ce que je suis d'accord avec
vous mais certains disent le monde irait
mieux sans agriculture parce qu'au fond
on retour à l'état de nature on va pas
retourner à l'état de nature on est on
est on est plus dans le
tempsen quel normes environnementales
allez-vous réduire alors alors c'est des
alors je vais vous donner un exemple
très concret vous avez une
réglementation sur la haie avec 12 ou 14
normes oui selon la police ou les
organisateurs comme disait l'autre
oui l'objectif du gouvernement c'est
qu'on a plus de la vérité c'est qu'on a
la les réglementations la plus sévère du
monde oui et que pour autant les
disparaissent d'ailleurs il y a pas que
de l'arrachage et c'est pas que le monde
agricole qui le fait donc on a quelque
chose qui va pas on a un objectif
environnemental de maintien et de
développement des c'est utile pour
l'agriculture c'est utile pour
biodiversité c'est utile pour
l'environnement seulement elles sont
tellement contraignantes qu'à la fin ça
on atteint pas l'objectif donc c'est
c'est une radicale simplification des
normes environnementales vous avez
parfois des normes environnementales qui
sont incohérentes dans un cas on vous
dit il faut
débroussailler et dans l'autre cas on
dit vous pouvez pas toucher parce que
c'est un hab vous écouté parler de la
tortue mais c'est vrai c'est une ce que
je vous dis vrai que la Tortue dans
leev dans le bah oui mais c'est une
ineptiie quand même on a construit
parfois une réglementation qui dit tout
et franchement le contraire de tout et
la tortue ou le reste elle brûle la
tortue la tortue si c'est pas des
broussill donc c'est voilà c'est
là-dessus qu'il faut qu'on travaille on
a besoin aussi pardon dans la réduction
des délais on voit bien qu'il y a des
gens qui se servent des procédures
réglementaire environnemental pour faire
de l'obstruction non pas qu'ils veulent
que les gens respectent l'environnement
ils veulent empêcher que les bâtiments
d'élevage se construisent parce que ils
sont contre l'élevage ça on va y mettre
un terme c'està-dire qu'on y aura pas
d'abus de juridique un certain nombre de
gens Marc fen le point peut-être
essentiel c'est le revenu de
l'agriculteur l'agriculteur ne vend pas
au bon prix son produit le produit de
son travail loi
égalime est-ce que un prix de base
théoriquement c'est un prix de base la
loi égalime mais c'est ça que ça vise à
construire puisque c'est le respect de
la matière première alors alors est-ce
qu'on devrait pas le F revenu c'est quoi
le revenu c'est l'écart entre le prix
vendu et le le couou travailler un peu
sur les coups dire que les n parfois
elles viennent renchérir le coup donc on
a besoin de travailler sur le coup le
premier ministre on y travaille fera sur
sur les sur la question des coûts les
coûts c'est l'énorme les charges il a un
certain nombre
dez Baer les charges ministre sur il y a
certains filières dont on sait que le
poids des charges quand vous êtes avec
beaucoup de main d'œuvre par exemple
sont des filières qui qui peinent
beaucoup par rapport à ceux qui sont
vous allez aider ces filières on va le
TR aller les charges de certaines
filières oui parce qu'on a besoin de
forcer un certain nombre de dispositifs
là-dessus deuxièmement sur le prix on a
besoin d'ors vous entendez peu de gens
en tout cas des gens sérieux qui qui
viennent dire qu'il faut revenir sur
égalim les gens ils viennent ils nous
disent plutôt il faut plus d' galimes il
faut mieux d'é galimes d'abord on va
faire respecter euh en renforçant les
contrôles ce que sont les attendus
d'galim c'est-à-dire le respect de la
matière première agricole oui alors
trois industriels accusés j'ai vu ça
d'enfreindre la loi égalim sanction très
lourdes c'est ce que vous avez dit non
c'est ce qui c'est ce qui est prévu
aprèsou mais moi j'ai vu préinjonction
c'est c'est pas tout à fait pareil he il
y a une il y a une procédure la
procédure prévoit une préinjonction et
après des sanctions très lourdes ça
dépend de la nature
du je je je pratique pas ça quand ça
sera uname ça existe oui mais là on est
dans une procédure de nature juridique
je pratique pas ça alors premier élément
deuxème élément on a besoin de
travailler avec les industriels et et
les et les et la grande distribution
d'abord la chaîne alimentaire si on veut
qu'elle soit souveraine il faut que tout
le monde fasse sa part donc chacun doit
faire des efforts et l'idée c'est pas de
chacun tirer de maximiser ses profits
sinon on n arrivera pas et puis deuxième
élément de regarder dans égalim ce qui
doit
être amélioré on a un sujet il y a un
certain nombre de filières qui ne sont
pas dans égalim la filière viticole
n'est pas dans égalim c'est son choix he
c'est pas nous qui la filière fruits et
légumes n'est pas dans égalim la
contractualisation n'a pas assez
progressé sur la filière bovine on a que
25 % à date de la filière bovine qui est
sous forme de contractualisation la
contractualisation c'est un moyen de
forcer à prendre la question du prix la
matière première agricole pour
construire le prix final ça il faut
qu'on travaille aussi là-dessus et il
faut qu'on y qu'on y en jooigne aussi
les les opérateurs de la transformation
et de la distribution oui qui doivent
aujourd'hui les industriels de
l'agroalimentaire et la grande
distribution terminer leur négociation
annuell c'est aujourd'hui ça se termine
c'est aujourd'hui que ça se termine en
espérant que ça va pas se terminer sur
le dos des agriculteurs he mais d'abord
on va vérifier que que Galim est opérant
oui il faut
qu'on pardon que par les contrôles on
fasse en sorte que ça soit opérant et de
il y a il y a un appel à la
responsabilité quand vous mettez 20 €
des000 litres de plus c'est
0,02 centimes d'euros sur le la brique
de lait donc il y a quelque chose dans
cette bataille mortifèire que se mène la
grande distribution qui est toxique à la
souveraineté alimentaire donc c'est un
sujet de responsabilité pour eux il y
aura des réunions d'ailleurs avec la
grande distribution vous allez les
convoqués oui on convoqu oui on n pas
chez
jug pas mal à sur le sujet j'ai eu
plusieurs sur le sujet pas très aimé
d'ailleurs par la grande distribution
mais je sais pas si c'est un titre de
gloire mais parfois il y a des des
amours qui qui sont des titres de gloire
d'accord j'ai une dernière question
parce que elle revient très souvent très
souvent vous l'avez entendu est-ce que
vous allez prendre des mesures pour
faciliter la transmission des
exploitations oui alors il y avait déjà
ce qu'on avait posé sur la table parce
que tout ça est quand même pas pas
ignorant de ce qu'il y avait il y avait
400 millions entrepreneurs du vivant qui
ont été annoncés par le Président de la
République qui était pour aider au
portage du foncier pour des jeunes qui
arrivent et qui ont pas la capacité 2
milliards d'euros qui était prévu aussi
de garantie bancaire pour faire en sorte
que le jeune qui s'installe il doit
emprunter 500000 ou un million d'euros
le banquier lui dit non monsieur vous
avez pas la surface donc ça c'était un
deuxième élément et on est en train de
travailler à des mesures avec les jeunes
agriculteurs qui sont très mobilisés
évidemment sur cette question à des
mesures de nature fiscale euh qui sont
en train d'être d'être c'est-à-dire
fiscal c'estàdire que c'est au moment de
la transmission comment on favorise pour
le cédent ou pour le repreneur on peut
le prendre parler debout de par des
mesures fiscales le fait que il soit
comment dirais-je ils soit incité à
moins d'impôt au au moment au moment où
on se réalise le bien si je peux dire au
moment on réalise le bien moins d'impôt
à payer voilà et donc ça c'est un moyen
dès lors qu'on transmet à un jeune h oui
parce que j'imagine ça doit pas aller à
l'angrandissement cette affaire là mais
c'est la volonté des jeunes agriculteurs
évidemment d'installer des jeunes on a
besoin d'installer des jeunes
agriculteurs donc ilura des mesures de
cette nature là mais faut répondre à
tout le reste aussi pour les jeunes
agriculteurs la question de la
rémunération la question des et la
question de la transmission et ça ça
sera bien dans le dans le paquet de
propositions qui seront qui seront sur
la table proposition avant la fin de la
semaine avant la fin de la semaine merci
Mar d'être venu nous voir ce matin sur
l'antenne de de Sud Radio beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup d'annonces vous
réagissez vous êtes agriculteurs vous
avez écouter Sud Radio ce matin 0826
300300 après les informations de 9h vous
pourrez dialoguer tous ensemble nous
dialogr tous ensemble à tout de suite